let's talk about assignment three this
is the fun stuff okay so there's a lot
of wiring that what is their assignment
who is where you need to do quite a bit
of mathematics and Donna there is only
the bus stop so this is one of that and
then I infer this is going to be way
after the previous assignments so it's
not like I'm gonna deadline of this next
to the previous assignment so after you
have completed that then you will still
have enough time to do it so lots of
blah blah blah there one please download
this zip file and there you can see the
implementation of my simple one de
monte-carlo integrator that we have
quickly put together a function any
function that in life and integrated
with the multi-color generator first
write it down in some way in latte and
put it in a PNG file or a PDF or
whatever and say that this is the you
know I would like to repeat and that be
the mathematician or be the engineer so
do do the actual calculation through
analytic integration or just open
Wolfram Alpha and let it do the hard
work and then we the multi column and do
the actual Monte Carlo something for
this function and see if you will get
the same results
so this is I'll conclude that your
calculations are correct now the pro
version of the same thing is modifying
the code to be suitable for higher
dimensional integration and then also
create any function and he where he
found polynomial cosine whatever
function that you would like exponential
forever and two multi-dimensional
multicolor integration this is literally
one line of code of a change and then
you can also integrate higher
dimensional functions which is very
small C++ program and if you feel like a
probe you can also evaluate the speed of
convergence so how does it look like how
far are we from the solution after 10
samples 10,000 samples 1 million samples
just plot the result and if you feel
adventurous you can also snatch my code
in this rendering program of small
things this is the one with the painted
walls we can smash my food for the
autumn you know discrepancies of series
and you can sample one or two or
whatever by national function with Hong
Kong series and you can see that how the
worst verified supposed a second part
this is the even more fun part there's
going to be a singing contest so we have
this want a column a freezer pop program
implemented in two hundred and fifty
lines we through the code try to
understand what's going on but we are
going to talk through this anyway and
just rather an interesting see just put
together a who's sitting with a given
number of objects see what you can do
with this and if you go to this website
you can you will be able to see a
gallery of the results from previous
years and and some of these guys and
girls have made amazing amazing artistic
sub with your result and make sure to
memory complete converges images don't
try this in the last five minutes this
takes time but it's insanely fun and as
in the previous years
we'll make this in this year a gallery
of the submissions so you can be proud
of your own work after you're done with
this course you can show your friends
how well you have done then obviously
subject is going to be the same only
plus I am very excited to see your
results even in the middle of the night
so I just met one of my former students
as friends and he immediately told me
that he has the fondest memories from
the relevant course because it was one
time later this assignment there -
behind and I'm so pleased
so I got an email from his results to
medium and that he was very delighted to
see that five minutes later so five
minutes after 3 a.m.
he got an answer with something like
fast train and he thought that oh my god
I messed up it's the mailer daemon
because uncertainty then five minutes
later power the million check it out
okay wonderful
ok that's basically it
yes